the big economic news yesterday gdp down
for the second quarter in a row many of
the haters said david you will never
cover this because you have to defend
the joe biden economy to the death and
no guys i don't care i don't care about
defending joe biden i don't care about
democrats i'm not a democrat i'm just a
progressive i report to you what is not
what i would like to see or what someone
else says should be
uh gdp fell 0.9
in the second quarter of 2022. this is
the second straight decline and it is
being called a strong recession signal
there is a traditional
uh delineation of what is a recession
which is two consecutive quarters of
declining gdp
and indeed on an annualized basis gdp
fell 0.9
that's following a 1.6 decline in the
first quarter and this was worse than
the dow jones estimate of a gain of 0.3
percent the drop came from a broad swath
of factors including decreases in
inventories
residential and non-residential
investment and government spending now i
am terrible at this i believe humans are
terrible at this
predicting economic uh futures
i don't believe we are headed to a
recession i believe we are going to have
better inflation numbers in a couple of
weeks in mid august we're going to get
the july numbers i believe they're going
to look good
i think there will be a nice little uh
uh potentially a little little market
rally there i it's not actionable i'm
not doing anything i'm not buying
selling suggesting anyone this is just a
prediction that i'm making i think q3 is
going to end up being so so and q4 is
going to be better now that prediction
is worth what you paid for it which is
nothing okay but this is my guess and
i'm going to tell you a couple of
different things why first and foremost
there's this
conventional wisdom which is often not
that wise
uh or conventional which is the american
economy by definition has a recession
every six to seven years at the most
every ten we are overdue for a recession
i don't tend to believe that that is
hard and fast
it's possible but difficult to avoid
recessions but it requires a very
balanced
stimulation of supply and demand
and you can
in some theoretical sense do this via
fiscal stimulus low interest rates
preventing shocks like the 2008
financial crisis due to mortgage uh
products that were predatory and fed
into the feedback loop
now it never happens right like
historically it just hasn't happened so
we've had recessions on this regular
basis i don't actually believe we have
to have true recessions but we are
certainly going to have pullbacks and
we've been experiencing a pullback i am
right now partial to the idea that we're
getting to the end of the pullback
rather than only the beginning
if you look at the reasons why
the decrease in gdp took place
they're not the most concerning reasons
i'll give you an example reduction in
inventories why would their reduction in
inventories lowers gdp
why would you have a reduction in
inventories well one reason can be that
people are buying everything when people
are buying everything and consumer
demand is so strong
it's not exactly a negative sign that
inventories have declined even though it
lowers gdp that's just one example
second there has been reduced federal
government spending
this is usually what right-wingers want
when there is government spending the
right-wingers go we can't afford it
inflation it's bad it's all terrible
well you know what happens when the
government spends less the gdp goes down
that's another reason that gdp is down
but it's not actually representative of
private industry struggling and again
private industries is doing very well
um
residential fixed investment has
declined non-residential fixed
investment like these are not the gdp
decreasing factors that to me signal
that a recession is coming now again
i'm an idiot i don't know anything and i
think even the people who do know stuff
are terrible at making predictions but
it's just not feeling when you look at
demand is really high
inflation is coming down
we are close to full employment
tons of businesses have open jobs that
they want to hire for
this doesn't
feel oh my god am i saying feel do facts
care about my feelings no they don't
this doesn't feel like we're heading
into a recession and i don't think that
the next six months are going to be
disastrous now would i take that to the
bank hell no
what am i doing i'm doing the same thing
i always do i've got my asset allocation
it's you know
uh 15 cash
three percent crypto i've got my real
estate i've got my stocks and bonds and
i just invest monthly regardless of what
the market is doing i'm not i don't even
trust myself enough in these predictions
to go and make any changes to what i'm
doing but that's my take on this and i
know that
uh and by the way
i don't credit joe biden for any of it i
would be listen i was right there when
barack obama remember barack obama obama
when he was running for re-election
and mitt romney was running against him
i said
i think the economy will be good the
next four years whether it's romney or
obama it might be a little different but
it's basically going to be a strong
economy
and it just was going to be a strong
economy and if it was if it was romney
uh then i would have had to say the same
thing it was pretty strong
during a period under trump the economy
was fine i would even say i wasn't on
here saying oh trump's economy is
actually terrible it was fine job growth
slowed down a little bit than where it
was under obama but stock market was
good consumer confidence was good
inflation was low it i i don't i don't
do the political games that many people
do around this stuff and right now my
sense is
this is not the start of some massive
recession let's see uh you know four
months from now six months from now
seven eight months from now uh come back
and check with me and we'll see where we
are hey this is really really funny
karl rove wrote an op-ed in the
washington india wall street journal
called
where do trump's donations go and it's a
very good question karl rove points out
he can't spend his packs millions on
2024 because he's not running
he's not using yet he's not using the
money
really to support midterm candidates
based on the spending disclosures that
we've seen
and i will add to that that yesterday we
found out that the republican national
committee is paying donald trump's legal
bills so what the hell is trump spending
the money on and karl rove who is a
anti-trump republican strategist says
what will donald trump do with his
campaign cash trump controls four-pack
save america
make america great again again
trump make america great again and make
america great again action
the pax cash on hand as of june 30th
came to 103 million 10 million 7.3
million and 700k that puts 121 million
dollars at trump's disposal
um small donors were pummeled with
requests for trump's causes in a 24-hour
stretch this week writes karl rove i
received 25 fundraising pleas from the
trump world beseeching me to help
america for the from the democrats save
america for the democrats in exchange
for donations i was offered a trump card
a blue one then a gold one then a
t-shirt then wine glasses then my name
on the donor wall and all these
different things and money is flowing
into trump's various packs but what is
he going to do with the money
karl rove writes one option is convert
the money to a presidential campaign
according to federal election lawyers
that's one possibility
what can trump use the cash for now well
he can support other candidates but he's
not really doing that
he could do independent expenditures on
behalf of candidates buying ads and this
sort of thing for other candidates but
trump hasn't done much of that either
what exactly is going to happen with
this money and karl rove writes if trump
doesn't start deploying these funds to
help the candidates he's backing donors
might not keep giving now there i
disagree with karl rove there is a cult
of personality around donald trump
where he could even admit i'm using the
money to hire my family
and refurbish my private jet and
whatever
and the vast majority of his followers
would say
all right i mean sounds like he needs
the private jet and his family are some
of the smartest people so it makes sense
to give them
the cult actually wouldn't really care
but it is an extraordinarily
consistent question that we have because
in the immediate aftermath of the 2020
election remember when trump lost but
said we're going to raise money and
we're going to audit this and we're
going to recount that and we're going to
do all these different things and they
didn't do it in the fine print it said
up to 50 or in some cases more of your
donation can be used to pay off campaign
debt
and so it's almost certainly some kind
of grift we just don't know what it is
yet now there's another kind of just
bigger picture thing
is trump
going to try to use the money to support
other candidates but not just out of the
goodness of his heart
conditionally in exchange for
favors
support in 24 whatever that's the other
idea which is trump will ultimately
relent and as we get closer to the
november midterms now we're only uh just
a a
you know a little bit over three months
away
trump will start to deploy the money for
the people that he's supporting but in
exchange for vows of uh loyalty going
into 2024. let me know your thoughts
what do you think trump's raising the
money for what do you think he's going
to use the money for but a great
question from karl rove where are the
donations actually going
make sure that you are following me on
twitter deepakman let me know where do
you think the donations are going and of
course make sure to sign up at
joinpackman.com the program is viewer
supported and i would love to have your
support we're going to take a quick
break it is a uh packed friday show
chock full
of content
as the kids these days say
don't forget that the best way to
support the david pakman show is by
becoming a member which gives you access
to the daily bonus show the regular show
with no commercials you also get access
to our entire archive of every episode
dating back
a really long time and plenty of other
awesome membership perks go to
joinpackman.com
and use the coupon code better21 for a
huge discount join pacman.com
the david pakman show is a viewer and
listener supported program which you can
support directly i'm telling you it's we
pay two percent to swipe credit and
debit cards and otherwise everything
else comes to us at
joinpacman.com sign up
get a membership it's a fantastic thing
and if you want a membership you can use
the discount code obama obama you'll
save some um it's got to be about 60 i
mean it's a criminal discount code let's
hear from some people in the audience we
take calls on the friday show via
discord you can find the discord at
davidpakman.com slash discord the
discord is free it is free to join it is
free in every way and it is how you can
reach me let's hear from some folks
starting with brittany in austin
brittany
am i correct that that's austin texas
yeah that's correct welcome to the show
good um i'm assuming you can hear
everything fine oh you're coming through
perfectly a little bit echoey but uh i'm
guessing you're you know in like an
italian shower or something like that
echoey that's really weird okay well um
i know he stated that many times he
believed the justice department should
prosecute donald trump if the evidence
points to illegal behavior sure um but i
worry about a scenario where they do
prosecute but ultimately the evidence
just isn't sufficient enough to convict
and how the end result could play out
for negatively for americans so like
and donald trump is accused of crimes
that ultimately result in a lack of
conviction for those crimes i think this
could be potentially catastrophic
because right now with the work from the
january 6 commission while donald trump
isn't formally convicted of anything we
all know that we all like know and
understand his role in attempting to
submerge subvert a democratic election
but if a case is presented and none of
the charges stick i'm worried that
public perception may shift about
january 6 and republicans could use this
as an opportunity to try similar things
in the future
under the guise that it wasn't illegal
and it wasn't i was just curious i tend
to agree with you brittany i think and
this is why i've said
if the evidence points in that direction
that is the most important thing if the
evidence justifies
and listen prosecutors it's not like we
need to tell prosecutors you should
really only do this if you think you can
get a conviction or at least a plea deal
on guilty
that's how prosecutors operate they
understand that and sometimes it's to a
fault and and sometimes cases aren't
prosecuted because prosecutors have
limited time limited resources and they
want to get wins so that's a known issue
but all of that being said i agree with
you if trump is charged
and there's not even like a guilty plea
deal whatever slap on the risk you've
got to at least get that if you don't
get that if you have an acquittal or
charges are dropped it is an absolute
and total disaster they will use it for
a decade and it will set everything good
back for a very long time and put at
risk future elections as you astutely
point out
yeah prosecution aside i definitely
think that we need to make sure the case
is strong enough before we
support um prosecuting because i just
get really worried about um those
charges not sticking but yeah thanks for
answering my question how's austin these
days you know austin is a popular target
for people to say oh it's ruined the the
liberals of ruined austin
um
i mean i love austin it's the only place
in texas i would live because me too i'm
not into the into the government um but
it's really hot so just be aware of that
fair all right brittany thank you so
much for the call
there is brittany from austin texas
let's go next to calvin
from indianapolis talvin welcome
calvin from indianapolis welcome
uh
well dave you can hear me yes i can
all right sorry if i didn't come to
claire the first time um i'll keep it
real brief had just a quick get response
question the second deeper dive question
sure good response with the washington
post posting last night that donald
trump is officially under investigation
do you really think anything is going to
come of that was it really just
investigating his cronies in a circle
around them and second question
knowing how good
the
right seems to be at charging its face
and getting the locals interested in
government seeing since our
basically since
the last politicians
excuse me and democrats have
no teeth when it comes to getting
anyone on the local level charge
wouldn't you think
it might be up to or good ideas for
platforms
and for lack of a better idea like
you're the young church like hey
we're going to expand out to
local stories or
try different ways to get
different individual states more charged
in the local base such as things that
you're saying hey you could phone lobby
for important races that you brought up
earlier
um for like a better word like mimidos
that race
i completely agree with you that would
be a great thing to do the difficulty is
for a national show where only you know
i i i my guess would be
no more than one percent of our audience
is actually eligible to vote in any of
like the state
particular state elections right like
how much of our audience votes in
pennsylvania is it one percent i don't
know how much of our audience votes in
you know matt gates district in florida
it's got to be it's a fraction of one
percent so the difficulty is
are we better off
talking about ways for people to get
involved locally so that they do it
wherever is local to them
rather than spending time in one
specific local race that very few of our
viewers might actually even be eligible
to vote in
and possibly alienate people who are
like that's not interesting that has
nothing to do with with my day-to-day so
this is a this is a challenge for
national shows and i don't know what the
answer is but i understand your
motivation for asking about about the
local focus
all right um thanks and once again to
that first question just to get response
do you really think anything major is
going to affect trump you know the doj
saying something or is that really
probably this is cronies i don't want to
deflate anybody but i still if you just
give me an even odds bet does trump get
indicted i still say no i'm closer to
yes than i've ever been but i'm still on
no talvin
yeah yeah yeah
unfortunately i kind of felt the same
way because
the report says
trump is under investigation but it
doesn't specifically say he's indicted
or anything well no but it wouldn't say
that the indictment would come later but
i know what you're saying i'm not
particularly optimistic
all right my friend calvin from
indianapolis thank you so much for the
call very very much appreciate it
why don't we go next where to even go
let's go to roy from south jersey roy
welcome to the program
uh good afternoon
welcome what's on your mind
um i just wanted to say that um the alex
jones conspiracy about uh vlad the
impaler and all that stuff yeah um from
a historical standpoint it doesn't make
any sense
uh the house that he was talking about
wasn't founded for another 400 years
vlad the impaler was not the progenitor
of all european dynasties etc so from a
historical standpoint it makes no sense
yeah i got an email about that let me
see if i can even find it it was pretty
funny
uh from someone who said
oh wait oh it was from you you're this
is just you emailed in
yeah you had a bunch of interesting
things where you explained that like
that the the the family he's saying is
the oldest family isn't and he's got the
lineages wrong and the funny thing is
like any normal person would listen to
that and know it doesn't make any sense
but then as you did when you actually
look into the specifics it makes even
less sense
right
um now i wanted to ask you a question
i've been called a monster for this okay
i shower with my glasses on um
am i a monster for that that i have
never heard of that ever i've never
heard of anyone doing that i will
sometimes shower with my contact on and
i know that that's controversial and
people will say oh sir you could get a
crazy infection from that um i mean i've
been doing it off and on for you know 20
years
but um
gla i have never heard of anyone
showering with glasses on how do don't
they get all steamed up
well yeah but then i'll just you know
wipe them off with my towel and then
i'll be fine wait you're bringing a
towel into the shower
well it'll be hanging out outside of it
and then i can just you know tuck my
head out and wash them off for a second
so how many times do you have to do that
during your typical shower
yeah like four or five so you're telling
me that what you do is you wear glasses
during the shower hang a towel outside
and then five times per shower lean out
to wipe them
that's correct wouldn't it be easier
just to take them off
um
probably but i've been doing it all my
life you know are you nearsighted
uh i'm farsighted oh so these are
reading glasses
yeah oh interesting and you need you
feel like you need those to shower
um i mean i don't want to like slip on
something or fall or whatever so
i kind of like feel more comfortable
with them on well listen safety is our
number one priority if that's what you
need to feel safe but it is certainly
unorthodox i will i will leave it there
roy
all right thank you for your assessment
you're still allowed in the audience
though it's not that crazy okay yeah
fair all right roy from south jersey wow
showering with glasses on i've never
heard of it never never heard of it very
interesting
let's go next to
now i'm gonna get this right this time
let's go to
elias
from texas did i get it right this time
so what's going on
oh okay um it seems like in the u.s the
folks that are concerned about climate
change are in the minority
when it comes to affecting public policy
how can we overcome the overwhelming
political odds
to pass meaningful legislation and how
can we get how can we do it quick quick
enough to hopefully avoid the worst
effects of climate change that are
predicted i don't know that i agree with
the premise now let's let's see if we
can clarify it you're saying
most of the general public doesn't want
to do anything about climate change or
most of our elected officials don't
i think i think elected officials is
like all the money that that comes from
oil companies and rights all of that so
here's the thing
most of the pop of the population does
want to do something about climate
change so the solution is
we need this is a crazy radical idea we
need to elect people
who will do the will of the voters and i
know it's like so quaint the problem of
course is between gerrymandering and
campaign finance and super pacs yeah and
all of these other voter suppression
techniques and all of it
we are not actually getting elected
officials that represent the will of the
people think about abortion right the
the will of the people is overwhelmingly
that abortion be legal in most cases if
you look at the senate that's not the
view in the senate of the hundred
senators yeah we've got a real problem
there we don't really have
representation
right is there okay if i follow up with
another question please elias go ahead
how do you feel about bringing a child
into this world knowing that you're
going to be saddling them with the
burden of living on a on an un
inhabitable planet yeah so here's the
deal with that
um
for me
i believe that only people are going to
solve the problems that we have and i
believe they are solvable
and so i know a lot of people have taken
this approach of i would never have a
kid because
the country the country's screwed the
planet screwed the species whatever
i think that if we don't
bring some people in who maybe could be
problem solvers we have no shot you miss
a hundred percent of the shots you don't
take
uh yeah and so i wanna have a shot at it
and so i want to bring someone in who
maybe could be someone that finds
solutions
yeah
wow thank you so much david all right
thank you for saying my my name's my
name correctly too that's my pleasure
thank you for the call all right very
good there is elias
let's go next to
esteban from orlando or we could say it
esteban
hello david i was actually on your show
like two years ago during covid and i
asked the question about uh nancy pelosi
and uh
impeachment articles and whether or not
it was a genius move i'm not too sure if
you remember that you know that
particular call i don't remember but i'm
so glad that you're back thank you so
much david um so i just wanted to kind
of have a mini rant and i wanted to get
your opinion and maybe uh shed some
light on one of the newest
i guess conspiracies uh that's being
spread by these crazy righties okay now
before you do that we have a couple
issues one is
we really want questions rather than
just a rant and then please react you
also have discord notifications blinging
in the background so right now the
call's hanging by a thread
okay uh
let me see i'm not too sure how i can
well let's do this
what was going to be your question at
the end of the rant and maybe i can work
backwards into the context okay so what
is the solution to responding to uh to
some of these conspiracies and and these
conspiracies are like pretty pretty
crazy i mean people are starting to say
that joe biden is apparently there's a
double now in the office and i just saw
this tweet and they posted footage of
biden you know talking and presumably
the differences between uh what biden
looks like in this video versus another
video it's all due to lighting and
whatnot you know just changes in his in
his uh
the way he tilt his head for example or
i don't know whatever whatever the case
may be
um some of these conspiracies regarding
this particular issue are so outlandish
and this to me is like next i have never
seen anything this this crazy before
like when it comes to like mainstream uh
politics so
i tried engaging with some of these
people um it was no luck
they just say that i'm creating
fantasies and making up stories
and i'm you know not opening my eyes
enough to what's really going on and
this type of a rhetoric is it's not
uncommon i mean it happens with tons and
other with tons of other types of uh
conspiracies and similar uh uh
situations so what would be
um i guess
or
uh what would be some advice
with regards to actually getting to
these sorts of people uh maybe refuting
some of these claims with actual facts
because it doesn't seem like actual
facts make any difference so is it
better to just ignore them it is better
to just ignore them yeah and i'm gonna
i'm gonna disconnect and maybe you can
just listen on the stream just because
the blinging is very very distracting so
here's the deal
some of these fringe conspiracy theories
i wouldn't even engage with them i mean
biden's got a biden's dead and there's a
body double that's up there with like
jfk or jfk junior are still alive and
running government alongside trump i
wouldn't waste my time on that there are
conspiracy theories that that are really
damaging like for example people who
think the vaccines give you covet for
example or stuff like that where it has
a public health impact um that trump won
the election even if that has a serious
voting impact but
the biden's a dead biden's debt and it's
a body double
is such a niche one that i would not
even bother engaging with that and the
thing is
you can't even really present facts
because it's there's no evidence for the
claim
so if you want to engage with it uh i
would just put the person making the
claim in the position of having to prove
it which obviously they can't but you're
there's no facts because it's a it's an
indefeasible claim you know it's sort of
like if i say there's an invisible uh
elephant in the room with me
okay
well
let's put
baby powder down on the floor so when
the elephant moves it'll disturb the
baby powder it's like no it's an inv
it's an invisible and weightless
elephant
oh okay well in that case let's
put food in it because eventually the
elephant's gonna need to eat and then
we'll notice the food no it's an
invisible weightless elephant that
doesn't need to eat you you know what
i'm saying okay so i just would not even
engage with that let's take a very quick
break
and then we'll get back and take more
calls so if you're holding on to talk to
me and you want to continue holding on
don't hang up and we'll be right back to
the phones
if you value what we do at the david
pakman show remember to support us on
patreon go to patreon.com
show where you can get access to behind
the scenes videos the daily bonus show
the commercial free daily show as well
as special discounts on merch including
hats hoodies mugs and t-shirts you can
support the show for as little as two
dollars a month check it out at
patreon.com davidpakmanshow let's go
back to the phone lines and hear from a
few more people you can join the
discussion at davidpakman.com
discord
let's go next to raj from ontario raj
welcome
hi david um i hope you're doing well uh
can you hear me well i can hear you fine
raj
okay i just wanted to first say thank
you for taking my call as well as for
holding a town hall especially this part
too to get everyone please also congrats
on your newborn i just heard about that
yesterday as well thank you um no
problem and uh my only question is uh
and i understand you're very busy but um
would you ever consider
um having an interview with canadian
author stephen marsh on the current
political situation in the u.s
and that's all i'll let you answer and
please stay safe and take care all right
i i've never heard of the person i'm
always willing to have interviews with
people that are interesting but i would
have to research
um the person and uh i wouldn't rule it
out is that fair yeah absolutely
absolutely i will soon be in canada so
i'm going to be undertaking my own
investigation as to who i should be
interviewing if that's fair
wow okay yeah i hope your i hope your
journey to canada is uh you know is a
smooth one and uh i hope you enjoy your
stay as much as you can yeah i'm gonna
try not to get stuck at the border you
know these things can get very very
crazy with the canadian border patrol i
i'm worried they will not like my
political activity and may not let me in
uh just a word of advice if you can
avoid pearson international airport
that's a big bonus because that's the
biggest one and uh you know
delays are usually going to happen there
but i you know i don't think you'll have
a any issues coming no i'll be i'll be
driving in i'll be going up 87 so it
should be i mean you know you can get a
line the cars start queuing up you know
okay excellent yeah i'm sure we'll have
a nice nice drive up here and there's
electric vehicle chargers in canada
oh our infrastructure's a little lacking
but like along the 401 and like you know
in metropolitan areas you won't have any
problem okay all right i don't want to
get stuck there that'd be humiliating
no it wouldn't be humiliating you know
things happen all the time everyone
makes products okay don't don't worry
about it do you i'm sure you'll you'll
find a way all right raj thank you for
the call
no problem thank you very much david and
take care all right you too very
important considerations there maybe i
should just rent a gas powered car i
don't know
all right let's go next to chris from
massachusetts chris welcome
uh chris is one of our moderators who
unmutes themselves regularly chris
welcome
thanks for having me pleasure i wanted
to ask um
do you do any like uh
you know outdoor sporting activities
like fishing or anything like that no
i've nev yes hiking yes
i have never done i recently actually
did some beautiful hiking in the
hudson new york area which is quite
an interesting area for hiking um i
fishing i don't do it here's the thing
about fishing it seems
so boring so so so boring and i get it's
like a sort of zen thing and you're out
there on the water and whatever it just
really seems boring to me
um
i mean i would disagree maybe uh because
you're not catching anything
well i don't know that i'm i'm not
catching or not i'm just not fishing you
know
there is the reason i ask is i just
wanted to kind of take this opportunity
to uh proselytize a little bit about
conservation
right now there's a bill uh called the
return act that was introduced by
um a republican and back has about 50 or
so republican co-sponsors
it's the return act and what it does is
it seeks to repeal the pittman-robertson
act uh in the dingle johnson act um
acts from the early
uh
20th century that put a 10 to 11 percent
excise tax on all
uh firearms uh ammunition
uh hunting fishing equipment
and the revenue from
this from these two bills
in some states makes up
about 60
of all of the conservation funding okay
um
for
you know maintaining state parks
uh maintaining uh public waterways
and uh
i think that because of how much funding
for conservation comes from
like the sporting and the outdoors uh
the the sporting part of the outdoors uh
community yeah um we on the left really
need to think of like some creative ways
to
you know continue to uh fund
conservation one of the uh proposals
that has been fought against by the
outdoor industry
um you know is a what people call a
backpack tax
this would be a similar excise tax one
to three percent on other recreational
uh
you know goods like boots dirt bikes
backpacks uh outdoor apparel
and um you know as somebody on the left
who is part of like who is a hunter and
an angler you know i get a lot of kind
of pushback from like you know people of
the left to have a distaste for
you know hunting and fishing which is
fine
um but
we can't
seed the conservation effort
to the republicans because they are
going to
continue just like every other you know
aspect of uh you know government
government funding they're going to try
to
undermine it abolish it and privatize it
that's right
without a doubt that's what they will
try to do chris i love the declaration
incredibly powerful did you have a
question for me
did i have a well the first question i
asked you was you know are you in the
outdoor are are you involved in uh
outdoor uh sporting activities
you answered but i uh then i i used my
opportunity to you know maybe encourage
people to
you know get out and start fishing i
guess all right well that is a uh an
activity among many which i encourage
the audience to consider
thank you david all right chris from
massachusetts with a number of different
items
on the agenda let's go next to yoink
from the philippines yoink welcome
can you hear me yes i can
all
uh i'm only using an earphone mic so i
think uh i think my audio is going to be
a little bit messed up for me for from
your part well let's do what we can
doing welcome
wow hello hello hello
um so uh i don't really have a
particular question in mind but i'm sure
you've heard
uh that
we have a new president yes a very
controversial one indeed yes
yeah indeed very much so
actually i was
a member here for a long time let's say
like
last year and i was just kind of
educating people and what they really
want to know and what they want to ask
anything about the philippines and so do
you have anything to ask me
a city or in a more rural part of the
philippines
i live in a city you live in a city okay
i live in yeah
so is life in a city in the philippines
i don't know how much you've tr have you
traveled for example to western europe
or the united states
i did travel to the united states once
but how do you think that life differs
how does life differ in a city in the
philippines in your opinion from life in
the united states
um
i wouldn't really call like the life
that i had because i was only there for
like a couple weeks but i could say that
i could say that it's much slower in the
united states whereas in here
well i wouldn't really say slower
because i've been in california and i
think new york is way faster
but in
in in like in california it's like
it's kind of down
it's
turned down a bit like in when it comes
to base but when it comes to like here
in the philippines especially when
you're like in the like mains like not
really the main streets but in like the
depths of the city you can really feel
like the speed and the things of the
things that are going on there so yeah
um
how would you is what's the relationship
like with the police where you are is it
generally speaking people have a
trusting relationship with the police
like i'll give you an example in
argentina for a very long period of time
like if you were going to be away for
two weeks you wouldn't let the police
know so that they would watch your place
because you would be worried the police
would break into your place whereas in
many places in the united states if
you're going to be away for a couple
weeks you call the police and they get
can you guys keep an eye on my house
because i'm not going to be here what's
the relationship like with the police
where you are
it yeah it has a little bit of like a
trusting effect because um especially
during the like the rodrigo duterte's uh
time yeah when he was still the
president especially at that time people
didn't trust them and now at least um at
least until
at least now this time
there's a little bit of a trusting
effect um especially when like oh okay
it's a new guy so maybe he will like
it's not that it's officiated that the
drug war has ended like the highly
controversial drug wars ended yeah but
it seems that you know it's not reported
as much anymore like
like i don't really hear anything
anymore like killings or stuff like that
i mean do you hear any more of killings
i mean i don't so killings from the in
the philippines you mean
yeah yeah yeah of the no i guess i'm not
i can't say i'm following it necessarily
that closely but
uh very interesting because
yeah
but because what i heard from that is
that there was a very controversial like
killing that even reached the the united
states it was like a student who was
just dragged out by a drunk police
officer then he was killed like in front
of a cctv camera and then the cctv
camera captured like
um the police putting
a bag of
meth or i don't know it's just it's
called it's i think it's cocaine yeah i
didn't see that one i didn't see that
one going but i i very much appreciate
the phone call thank you
yeah yeah thanks thanks all right thank
you from the philippines hope to hear
from you again
let's hear from a couple of other people
why don't we go next to colin from
oregon colin welcome
hi david how are you thank you for
having me on the air pleasure i have a
few ques oh yes thank you i have a few
questions to ask you if that's okay well
let's see what the first one is and then
we'll evaluate
i'm curious about how you feel about the
west coast's relevance to politics
um uh well let me so do you mean just
because
with those three left-leaning states
that are reliably left-leaning at the
federal level like does it does does it
make a difference what happens in the
states is that sort of what you're
saying yeah
yeah so we hear i know you live on the
east coast um or i know you're a world
traveler that's kind of remarkable in my
opinion but we we talk about a lot ohio
and iowa and a lot of these caucuses and
we decide that these midwestern states
really decide the abandoned fold of
which direction the federal court and
the federal
um
government leans but the west coast so
gavin newsom is making all these
big appearances but the west coast also
made claims saying like we're not gonna
corroborate with these states that are
anti-abortion we're not gonna cooperate
um
yeah what do you think about that i
think that the west coast is is relevant
and i have to you know no offense to
washington and oregon
but california is an absolute behemoth
economically and culturally and so yes i
mean you've got this state that is
really like a country it's got a larger
population and a larger land area than
many countries around the world running
the state of california is a bigger job
than running many countries and that is
of massive and significant importance um
and so i do think that
in particular california i'm not i'm not
putting down washington and oregon but
it's such a behemoth that it is an
economic leader it is a cultural leader
it is also a media leader and so i think
it's of a massive consequence an impact
so you think that it
my next question is
do you really follow western politics
closely or is it kind of on your side
sides more like okay i'll check that
over once in a while or is it really
important to you no listen i mean i
don't follow the internal politics of
oregon
any more or less than i follow the
internal politics of indiana even though
it's further away from me i'm not
following it less or more it's just i
think people in my position we tend to
follow what's going on locally to us
and then the big flash points and
certainly florida and california are two
of those
and then people are kind of living live
so but but it's there's no particular
reason i'm not following oregon politics
it's just i'm also not following north
dakota politics or michigan politics
yeah i just respect your opinion and
you're a political person and oregon's
politics and washington's politics they
we if you haven't noticed we kind of
the the governors came together and said
we are not going to cooperate with
states that are going to persecute
people that come to our states to seek
abortions yes do you think that's going
to
strike some political strife is that
going to cause some civil divide it is
and we're seeing it because there are
states already thinking about responding
to that by saying we are going to
criminal criminalize anybody who helps
someone go to another state for an
abortion that may be legal there so that
is becoming a fight
it's really unfortunate that is that's
all i have david thank you thank you for
your time colin from oregon thank you so
much for the call
many good calls today many i think is
the right way to say it i appreciate
everyone who called in i can't speak to
anyone else today
but i will speak to more people very
very soon quick break and back after
this
follow us on social media interact with
the david pakman show community see
exclusive content see when we're taking
calls live and stay up to date on other
big show announcements we post daily
find us on reddit twitter instagram
facebook discord and tick tock
all right let's get into the week's
mailbag you can always email info
davidpakman.com we have a variety a
smattering of different thoughts and
prayers and emails and different things
to look at this week um occasionally we
will look at youtube comments or tweets
or whatever the case may be but mostly
emails all right let's go to our first
one mary wrote in about donald trump and
said i loved his alaska rally and i
hated all your little stupid comments on
the side i think you're a complete idiot
well two points to marry for correctly
using the contraction of you are y o u
apostrophe r e it's almost a legal
requirement when you send me hate mail
that you incorrectly put in y o u r we
see that almost every day so mary
congrats as a reminder
i will say whatever the hell i want
during my streams and if you don't like
it find a different stream this is my
stream at the end of the day and i'm
allowed to talk over your president as
you like to refer to him as much as i
want
thank you mary
mike from new york city wrote in about
the who is the president question and
says big fan of the show recently you
asked election fraud
conspiratorialist darlene swaffer who is
the president how is this question asked
in better faith than republicans who ask
what is a woman when hearing testimonies
from trans advocates aren't they both
gotcha questions
no mike who is the president is not a
gotcha question
when i ask who is the president it's a
good faith
check as to whether they can
tell me a simple fact it's sort of like
do humans need water to live it's a yes
or no question the these are not trick
questions and if they are unable to
answer it it really says something about
them the what is a woman question is a
question that's deliberately contrived
first of all to blow up an issue that is
a minor political issue that's number
one and then number two
it's a question
that is being asked
out of context and then misused to
answer questions that are either legal
questions or questions of competition in
sports or about abortion or whatever the
case it's the epitome of bad faith when
i say who's the president if they go the
president's joe biden go
fine i'm not go looking to use that in
any particular way it's the opposite of
a bad faith question so no there's
really no similarity there whatsoever
aaron wrote in about donald trump's
dancing says hey david it's aaron from
hull england i've been to hull
from hull england writing huge fan of
the show i was wondering what your
thoughts are on donald trump's dancing
after rallies it's always perplexed me
as to his motives behind the dancing do
you think it's to come across as more
affable or lighthearted i'd love to hear
your thoughts on the reasons behind his
dancing no here's what it is with trump
and his dancing trump
not accidentally but on a whim
trump danced for like five seconds once
at a rally and
his the crowd liked it
and it started to be memed and his
supporters loved it
and he got the attention that he wanted
for it positive attention rather than
negative attention and so he just does
it all the time that that's all that
you have to
the lens through which we interpret all
of these actions by trump
is a lens of self-centered narcissism
that's fundamentally the most important
thing
and so the reason trump does anything is
to get what he hopes and believes is or
will be positive attention and he even
does it the dancing now
at horrible
times like he danced at the he spoke at
the nra
72 hours after the horrible texas
shooting
uh made a mockery of everything at the
speech and then danced after the fact
it's all in poor taste it's all for
self-aggrandizement
kyle wrote in
kyle says hey i need to talk about
something my mom's cousin sends her
stupid political stuff and my mom thinks
75 percent of democrats regret the way
they voted i don't think that's an
accurate statistic at all what do you
think what would you say
her cousin is always sending her stupid
political crap yeah so listen it's hard
to debunk things i haven't seen but i
have seen no evidence whatsoever that 75
percent of democrats regret voting for
biden over trump i am not a democrat but
i'm on the left i voted for biden over
trump do i think biden is the best thing
since
sliced cracked wheat bread no
is biden the best thing since nova
smoked salmon no of course not
um but was it obviously the right
decision given the given the alternative
110
so it sounds completely made up
if you look at biden's approval of 37
37 is low
but there's no way that the vast
majority of the disapproval is
republicans so you have to sort of see
if these numbers pass the sniff test
if of the 63 it's really some people
have no opinion so it's like high 50s
but of the 60 percent that disapprove of
biden's handling as president
most are republicans and so you have to
realize by that alone it just doesn't
make sense that 75 of democrats regret
voting for joe biden so ask her to
provide a source is the best advice i
can give you
violence if trump is indicted this came
up on the show the other day
and a viewer doesn't think i should be
talking about it
who said quote i think it's smarter
not to talk about that the democrats are
cowards enough for many and all threats
the republicans make do you want them to
really think about these potential
threats when evaluating whether or not
to indict trump think that's smart i
don't but love your thoughts most of the
time yeah listen
merrick garland is not considering
whether trumpists will be violent
in terms of figuring out whether he
wants to indict donald trump i think
merrick garland is thinking more about
his
career
and how it will look for a department of
justice to indict a former president i
don't think that it's a factor and one
of the things i won't do on this show
is sort of like strategically hide
things from you for optics reasons i
believe there's a real chance that if
trump is indicted republicans will get
violent i'm not going to hide that
um
it's a topic of discussion it's a very
real one after january 6th in particular
so i think the smartest thing i can do
is to be honest with the audience and to
say what i believe the truth to be
and what i believe is likely to happen
in the future
a millie wrote in about gavin newsom
and says dear mr pacman i agree with you
about gavin newsom for 2024. what do you
think about pete budege
the they called him booted leg booty leg
but i call him boot edge edge for vice
president i think they would make a
powerful team watch your show daily keep
up the good work best to you and yours
amy yeah i mean listen
if you want to make an identity politics
argument it's like two more white guys
what
um the reality is that gavin newsom and
p buddha judge are two highly highly
skilled politicians
they play offense rather than defense
which the democratic party desperately
needs right now now in terms of boot
edge edge for vice president
but normally i wouldn't even be talking
about 2024 before the 2022 midterms
because the two elections are so linked
we're talking about both
in relation to each other i've said i
think newsom is a skilled politician who
could be interesting in 24 i think
buddha judge is a skilled politician who
could be interesting in 2024 so let's
first figure out the nominee
let's deal with vp later but there is no
question that buddha judge is a very
good when he goes on fox news at
just completely disarming and
disassembling these contrived right-wing
framings of issues and that's really
what they are
nathan wrote in about right-wing
derangement here's nathan's theory
theory the right wants to make the
entire middle of the country
uninhabitable for all but the hardest
right of the right-wing nut jobs forcing
reasonable humans to fewer and fewer
states on the coasts enshrining minority
rule
solidifying indefinite control over the
senate all future judicial appointments
and clinging to fascistic power
indefinitely could this be why there
seems to be no bottom to the absolutely
depraved arranged policy positions
they're willing to take so there is no
bottom to their depravity nathan's right
about that but this doesn't seem like
what the idea here is republicans want
to make red states so horrible for
liberals that all the liberals leave
now in the senate that can be useful
because you can increasingly have
minority rule wherein
uh a minority of where senators
representing a minority of the
population
control more than half the senate we've
talked about that math the math works in
the senate the problem is if all the red
states lose population
at the census
they will lose uh members of the house
and that's not good for them and also
it doesn't help them win uh presidential
elections
so i i i think they would have no qualms
morally about approaching uh
employing such a strategy nathan but i
don't think they're doing it i don't
even know that they're that organized
and also it doesn't really seem like it
would work when you look at the math of
it
blake wrote in blake says i'm a
subscriber and i very much appreciate
and agree mostly with your show
however i also respect and appreciate dr
joseph mercola i'm not sure why some of
the left has trouble with dr mercola it
would be incredibly educational
if you could critically
interview him thanks for reading yeah i
mean the thing about dr mercola is he's
one of the most notorious anti-vaccine
anti-science voices
in the sort of like quack community
so it's not for me
it's just not for me
last one anthony says trump says that
investigations of him are politically
motivated so what if an investigation is
into his activities reveals a crime what
does it matter if the investigation was
politically motivated well it doesn't
matter if it's politically motivated in
terms of the criminality what we
wouldn't want is a crime committed by a
hundred people
where only republicans are democrats are
targeted for it that would be a problem
trump's crimes are highly political and
in that sense it's not
the wrong term to say politically
motivated but the problem with political
motivation is when we talk about
unfair application of the law it's not
what's happening with trump that's for
sure we've got a great bonus show for
you today
uh sign up at joinpakman.com use the
coupon code bigvoting22
i will see you then